voilà mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
retour donc à l'actualité durant cet
entracte à l'opéra de paris à la fin de
cette édition nous vous donnerons tous
les résultats des matchs de football qui
se sont déroulés ce soir pour le compte
du championnat de france
auparavant je propose de faire une
petite place aux turfistes et bien sûr
aux chevaux demain
le président de la république va en
effet déserté l'elysée pour se rendre
comme des dizaines de milliers
d'habitants de la région parisienne à
longchamp demain c'est en effet le grand
jour pour les turfistes et par
conséquent pour les chevaux qui va
remporter le prix de l'arc de triomphe
il ya eu six partants et je ne me
hasarderai pas faire un pronostic
d'autant plus qu' il y aura sur le champ
de main des casaques très connu mais
aussi des couleurs de certains
propriétaires qui tentent l'aventuré
pour la première fois l'enjeu est
tentant un million deux cent mille
francs d'aujourd'hui pour le cheval qui
rapportera le prix de l'arc de triomphe
nous en reparlerons demain à 13h
longuement les otages orly air avec le
résultat que vous connaissez dacca
depuis trois jours
dix passagers de la viande et japan
airlines ont été libérés en début de
soirée contre le versement d'une rançon
de trois millions de dollars il reste
encore cent trente et une personnes à
bord
mais la moitié de ses passagers va être
libéré dans les minutes qui viennent
enfin zouhair at the era vous vous
souvenez peut-être le 1er mai dernier un
commando du front polisario a attaqué la
petite bourgade de zohra tu en
mauritanie et enlevé six français
aujourd'hui les familles de ces six
français ont lancé un appel aux
dirigeants du front polisario et aussi
aux responsables politiques pour qu'ils
cessent de spéculer sur la vie des
otages innocents
ces familles ont également été reçus au
ministère des affaires étrangères une
entrevue qu'elles ont qualifiée de
décevante voulait donc d'être reçu par
le ministre des affaires étrangères
qu'est ce qu'on vous a dit pourtant
monsieur de birago déclaré récemment que
autres femmes et les cinq autres otages
étaient en bonne santé est vivant et en
bonne santé
sahil a eu bat affaires étrangères
algérienne nom de notre côté nous sommes
associés entre les familles d'otages là
ont pris un avocat et nous ayons si
notre côté de taper à toutes les portes
or députés ça n'apporte rien de vaut
depuis cinq mois aucune nouvelle aucune
nouvelle en ce qui concerne la faire
proprement dite qui s'est passé le 1er
mai la prise d'otage selon vous qu'est
ce qui porte la plus grande part de
responsabilité à mon avis la société
dans laquelle je travaillais étant donné
qu'elle aurait pu nous prévenir qu'il y
avait danger et la mauritanie qui n'a
rien fait enfin l'armée mauritanienne
qui n'a rien fait ce matin là la preuve
encore c'est la société est assez
bizarre qui n'ont eu recours au vote
pour aller travailler de nouveau en
mauritanie étant donné que ma femme est
encore prisonnières qu'on n'a aucune
nouvelle
qu'est ce que vous allez faire
maintenant rien je pense je sais pas
tout ce que je sais que moi les
histoires de mauritanie d histoire
politique et tout j'en ai rien à [__]
tout ce que je vois c'est la libération
de la femme et celle de les amis enfin
bien plus parce que c'était cinq copains
moi et j'étais en train de faire une
lettre à ma femme je ne peux me
permettre de la lire c'est possible
nicole j'espère que toi les autres vous
êtes vivants et en bonne santé
nous avons quant à nous aucune nouvelle
directe dans ce qui vous concerne nous
demandant quelles sont vos conditions de
vie
si toi tu ne souffre pas trop de la
chaleur ou du manque d'hygiène
depuis cinq mois je suis complètement
paumé j'espère que ça ne va pas durer
trop longtemps
plus le temps passe et puis j'ai le mal
de vivre seul sans toi cette lettre je
t'ai literie comme une bouteille à la
mer sans même savoir si un jour elle ne
parviendra je t'aime christian g demande
qui pourrait faire parvenir cette lettre
peut-être que monsieur ghislain goût
pourrait faire quelque chose rien
appelle le pathétique que nous voulions
vous passer ce soir les conversations
politique de monsieur raymond barre à
moscou sont terminées le premier
ministre français a d'ailleurs quitté la
capitale soviétique pour un bref séjour
touristique kaliningrad et en ce moment
même comme vous l'êtes vous même sur
antenne 2 et bien monsieur bart est à
l'opéra
il quittera à l'urss demain dans la
soirée pour rentrer à paris monsieur
jaubert lui poursuit son itinéraire
politique l'ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères du président pompidou a
présenté ce matin à la presse les
candidats de son parti pour les
prochaines élections législatives il
s'agissait d'une première présentation
72 candidats du mouvement des démocrates
étaient présents monsieur jaubert
espérant présenté au total à peu près
200 son but
arbitre et l'affrontement majorité
opposition en nous présentant des
candidats
d'abord pour affirmer notre présence
ensuite parce que nous pensons que nous
aurons la possibilité d'arbitrer ce que
nous avons toujours considéré comme un
jeu indigne des français c'est-à-dire
l'affrontement à parts égales vd
français ne pensez vous pas que votre
action va brouiller les cartes des
partis politiques des grands partis
politiques pour les élections
législatives
écoutez les une image kiwi d'être ils
sont assez grands pour les brouiller
entre vous le voyez ne m'imputer pas ce
qui leur revient de droit
enfin point de vue tactique
en cas d'échec au premier tour est-ce
que vous avez des prévu des désistements
pour d'autres partis venons tous écouté
tout cela est de la combine ça fait
trois ans que je dis que les voies
appartiennent aux électeurs et ce sont
les électeurs qui décident ce qu'ils
font un moment ils se portent sur un
candidat
de telles parties et ensuite si ce
candidat n'est pas dans la course qui
font un autre choix c'est leur affaire
mais aucun parti je le répète n'est
propriétaire des voix aucun est en tout
cas nous n'aurons jamais cette attitude
et je l' ai toujours dit les français
face à la télévision le problème est à
nouveau posée depuis quinze jours trois
semaines de plus aux réalités que la
controverse au sein de l'union de la
gauche a quitté le sanctuaire des salles
de réunions pour être dévoilée sur la
place publique via la télévision
l'émission samedi et demi que
présentaient jean pierre elkabbach
aujourd'hui à 12h30 sur antenne 2 et est
d'ailleurs consacré à ce problème parmi
les invités il y avait monsieur
caillavet qui est chargé par le sénat de
s'occuper justement de tous ces
problèmes de l'audiovisuel et de la
télévision
alors la question a été posée faut-il
réformer la réforme dans le show
business c'est vrai nous avons recueilli
des observations désagréable et je crois
qu'il sort de notre devoir de
transmettre aux présidents de chaînes
qui sont responsables les observations
que nous on que nous avons recueillies
pour assainir dix ans ce domaine je suis
personnellement hostile aux sondages
je le dis je le propose il faut
supprimer les sondages car à tout
prendre vous le savez les éléments de
qualité l'emportent pour trois quarts
contre un quart à l'audience et des
langues pourquoi ne pas créer un
organisme
il serait facile de le créer le des
représentants de l'état des
téléspectateurs et des parlementaires et
la redevance ray dans ces conditions
ventilé selon le respect porté au cahier
des charges ou et l'allemand la qualité
propre du spectacle c'est encore une
proposition de réforme
je pense aussi que il faudra car c'est
le but de télévision c'est la création
il faudra donner toutes leurs chances à
l'ensemble des réalisateurs aujourd'hui
nous le savons il y a des baronnies il
ya des clans il ya des satrapies on a
ferme on affirme littéralement l'écran
cela n'est pas acceptable parce que
pendant sept ans des dizaines de
personnages d'hommes de qualité ne
peuvent pas s'exprimer avec une écriture
télévisuelle qui est particulièrement
séduisant on l'a dit depuis des années
mais c'est pas parce qu'on leur on l'a
dit le pistolet qu'il faille pas le cas
hier des cidreries le proche orient
on attend ce soir la publication
simultanée à washington et à moscou
d'une déclaration américano soviétique
qu'il s'agirait d'un appel des deux
grands aux états arabes et à israël pour
que reprenne la conférence de genève m
klose croissant appréhendé hier par la
police française attend de comparaître
lundi devant la chambre d'accusation de
la cour d'appel de paris premier acte
juridique d'une éventuelle extradition
aujourd'hui en allemagne l'un des
associés de la vocal andreas baader a
lui aussi été arrêté
il est présumé coupable de constitution
d'organisations terroristes
et puis incidents en italie plusieurs
milliers de jeunes manifestants ont
défilé dans les rues aujourd'hui à rome
à milan à bologne à turin ces
manifestations avaient été organisées
par des mouvements d'extrême gauche
après la mort d'un jeune militant
gauchiste tués hier par un commando
d'extrême droite à plusieurs reprises
aujourd'hui des bagarres très dures ont
opposé manifestants et policiers à 20
ans martin à la réunion a fait quoi pour
vous sur les connaissances et les
progrès de la lutte contre le cancer
notamment contre le cancer du sein
elle a choisi ce soir de revenir ce
sujet de revenir pardon sur ce sujet
parce qu'au-delà des nouvelles
stratégies élaborées par les
cancérologues
il existe une foule de petits moyens
pour dépister un éventuel cancer une
foule de petits moyens à la portée de
toutes les femmes si elles sont
informées et si elles veulent bien y
penser
bien sûr le cancer du sein
c'est la grande peur des femmes car
cette affection ali de crainte celle
d'une tumeur est celle d'une atteinte
esthétique disons le mot d'une
mutilation
depuis que les traitements par les
radiations les hormones et la chirurgie
large ont donné leurs premiers résultats
les méthodes de diagnostic et de
traitement se sont affinés et leurs
progrès se sont traduits en années de
survie
même si les résultats à long terme ne
sont pas toujours aussi favorable qu'on
le voudrait pour tout il faut dire
qu'une tumeur et silencieuse durant près
de huit ans avant d'atteindre 1 cm et
d'être perceptible au diagnostic mais il
faut aussi ajouter que les résultats
seraient encore meilleurs
si les femmes parvenait à vaincre soit
leur peur soit leur négligence car elles
ont le moyen par des gestes simples
régulier d'apprendre elle même a décelé
une grosseur suspecte à partir de 35 ans
les femmes doivent juste après l'arrêt
de leurs règles apprendre à palper leurs
deux seins debout puis allongé et bien
entendu signaler à leur médecin toute
anomalie en se rappelant que toute
grosse heure n'est pas une tumeur que
tout tumeur n'est pas un cancer mais que
le cancer peut commencer par l'une de
ces anomalies des pistes et aux traités
sans précipitation avec le concours de
plusieurs moyens dont depuis peu le
secours de l'immunologie et de la chimie
on peut espérer dans bien des cas guérir
les femmes en préservant leur sein les
sports il y avait une journée de
championnat de football ce soir d'année
le gazole les résultats tout de suite et
bien les résultats tout de suite
monaco à monaco a fait match nul avec
nantes un but partout 1 but de nice d'un
côté un but de la combe de l'autre a
paris nous allons voir des images tout à
l'heure nice a gagné 3 0 bastia a battu
roanne 3 2 nancy a battu lyon 3 1 à
bordeaux marseille a battu bordeaux 2 1
reims a battu valenciennes 3-0 hier
strasbourg avait battu metz 5 1 ce soir
encore laval a battu sochaux 3 1 et lens
a battu 3 3 à 2 et hier saint-etienne
avait battu nîmes de busan et tout de
suite nous allons parc des princes pour
voir un petit peu ce match qui
promettait beaucoup et que les parisiens
ont malheureusement totalement manquée
et nous allons voir que pourtant les
parisiens dès le
la 10e minute avait failli ouvrir le
score nous attendons ça m'arrive c'est
un match qui vient de se terminer il
faut le dire il en est depuis monté que
la première mi temps parce qu'elles ont
des problèmes d'image
voilà c est alors regardez bien sûr
cette première action on va croire on
croit que paris va ouvrir le score
la défense dégage et paris va encore
obtenir un coup franc je précise que les
niçois jouent en blanc et sur ce coup
franc joué très vite c'est un tir
lointain de la défense qui est repoussée
1 par nice dahleb reprend et ferron
repousse ensuite la défense dégage en
corner et puis à la 11e minute regarder
cette balle qui s'en va loin en avant
pour sanchez sanchez l'ailier droit qui
n'est attaqué par personne là tout le
temps de descendre le terrain de se
rabattre et louvre pour jouve ou huit
agents d'ouvrir le score 1-0
et puis à la 32e minute sur ce coup
franc j'ouvre barrage à la cites au coq
topo pour bjekovic et bjekovic marque le
deuxième but un troisième but sera
marqué en deuxième plutôt bien non il
nous n'avons pas le temps de les
présenter ce troisième but aux
téléspectateurs en effet cette édition
est maintenant terminée l'entracte à
l'opéra est terminée alors je vous
laisse se poursuivre cette soirée avec
rossini notre prochain journal et demain
à 13 heures bonne fin de soirée